[Music]
okay
logan paul
okay let's watch this clip run it
you know this you know this clip
everybody if you don't basically
you're going to find out
basically i'm not going to explain it
you're going to find out
so basically
it's a story i'm interested in the story
i just talked to logan paul
i mean like he was just being nice and i
get it media whatever he has to be nice
pause it before i approached him he was
okay i haven't seen some [ __ ] like this
in forever i don't know why but this
gave me like old internet vibes yeah
you know yeah like this gave me like uh
leave brittany alone vibes
[Music]
leave brittany alone this is classic
like
early early internet where you didn't
think things would go viral or be seen
by a lot of people you just kind of like
did it yeah and dealt with it after or
like yeah early early influence or early
youtube vibes too when people like
didn't know that you
can't just really approach people yeah
and say whatever you want you know i
don't know yeah anyway let it rip my guy
he's bragging about making three million
dollars
i make a hundred thousand dollars a year
22 i do make 100 000 that's cool and i
wanna
i wanna act i wanna i wanna do these
things
[Music]
i'm gonna break down right now
me too brother oh i'm sitting in the
cast i don't know what to do
like i did come up here by myself
i do have family but
we're not the closest i killed them all
i don't have really close friends
you know there's millions of people
trying to do what i'm trying to do
just watch the clip okay
sneak everyday no i know i didn't i quit
my job you know wait
i quit my job legit two days ago i came
up here took a risk i'm originally from
ohio
no i didn't sing in here i didn't think
what do you mean like on stage are you
just like yes i did you're one it's one
of the sneak on the sneakers
did you print the ticket and stuff no i
just need to talk to you i really i'm
trying to talk to your brother i'm
trying to talk about business trying to
talk about trying to get a job
like i want to i want to do media i want
to i've been trying to get what are you
good at i was having dances i did like
that i did i did that video you know
like i'm like oh yeah yeah you know
unless you really got what it takes yeah
i don't i don't then why would i need
him
why would i do that i want to be i want
to be like
i'm 22 years old i'm just trying i bet i
can't be a mentor right now right in my
life i'm a [ __ ] up myself i need a
mentor you know what i'm saying like i
need you connections you need people to
be around you no i don't have
connections with people right i have
jake that's it you have a brother you
have people i don't like are they
friends you gotta you got friends
you don't have friends i don't i swear
to god
i'm here by myself i'm here by myself
where are you from i'm from norway
you're a good looking guy bro you have
friends bro you're [ __ ] lying you
have friends
go make content do stuff with your
friends i'm glad you quit your job it
takes balls to do that bro but like now
you got to actually try to make a step
but i'm not the guy directly you are the
you're def you're the guy you're the guy
my team is
this
i'm not the guy like you know life isn't
about handouts you know what i'm saying
i know
i'm trying to work hard for a little
money no money i don't know i can get a
job somewhere else all i want to move to
la and i want to i want to be able to be
part of that look i have to go if you
really are serious about it bro you
should move to la and just like you
approached me start making connections
with every single person i'm serious
i've always said this if you have if
you're charismatic and you can talk to
someone you could make it in l.a that's
my advice
i quit my job
[Music]
logan's a dick
he's hot though
logan definitely should have hired that
guy on the spot yeah dude give him a job
so what bro sleeping on it talent man
yeah
make him the head of nfts for you yeah
damn damn
yo this guy you're my chief nft officer
damn that sounds like uh
that sounds like a pet name for like
crypto dudes yeah
yeah
you're my chief nft officer don't
[ __ ] play with me bro you're my pudgy
penguin you can be my fan gang
i'm oh you're bored when i'm aping with
you but you want to mint this alka bone
give me your loot
[Laughter]
i'll show you minty little alka bone
right here
yeah nah
this dude's account is
if you go he like made a shirt
logan can i have it
made a video and i'm gonna post it
what am i gonna do
you got a job for me and they're just
mocking them you're tired bro already
thank you logan i texted love
you know
man you know what it is man and i was
like hey man it's [ __ ] up you know
what i was like
you know what i'm gonna embrace this
[ __ ] because people want to make fun of
me i'm going to make fun of myself [ __ ]
it if i make bro hello good looking guy
looking guy bro you have friends bro i
need a job
logan i need a job
all right i finished the shirt
damn
[ __ ] so that was after the whole thing
happened yes after he killed his whole
family then he went
to go see he snuck it to see logan
dude you have friends man no i seriously
don't i killed them i killed them all
i'm serious when i say i do not have
friends dude come on you're a good
looking guy you have you want to go see
him you want to go see him let's go to
tennessee i used to have friends
i mean of course logan i used to have
friends
but i don't anymore oh no
i think you want to give me a job
this is you know capacity for the joker
arc this guy right here
yep yes
yeah this is same vibes as
like the next being on the show yeah
next time like
logan is gonna wake up
on an airplane
him and the whole squad like
like chained up in their first class
seats
and this dude's gonna be walking up the
aisles
and he's gonna be like
just holding the pilot hostage with a
serrated blade
he's like now logan
we got the gang on here
we're all we're like this we're all like
this dude aren't we
just come on say it we are right
someone's got to get us home
and we're going down as we speak
so who wants a pilot
you need a pilot logan to bring us home
pilot tries to get away
[Music]
oh jeepers he wasn't part of our gang
though was he logan
neither was everyone else in the back so
i took care of it
look down the aisle the whole second
passenger oh my god
logan just starts crying he's like
trying to get out of the thing what's
wrong logan you're a good looking guy
you got nothing to worry about
so tell me logan can i have a job now
you want to hire me to fly the plane
logo's like yes yes yes
you can slide the plane
too late he just runs straight into the
[ __ ] i don't know how to fly he runs
up to the escape hat
that's logan mike and all the podcasts
like
papers flying everywhere
dead the dead bodies for a [ __ ] coach
[Laughter]
not first class
just getting all piled up in the door
just
then logan wakes up
lays back down and then sleeping right
next to him have a bad dream
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] man
yeah don't do that
don't
do that
but that guy did you can't do that man
oh man he
like
what a really really bad way to handle
it too like the first
there's so much lost in translation
there in the first like 15 seconds of
that conversation he's like oh you're
one of those guys that sneaks into
events and does youtube videos right
yeah he's like no yeah i mean yeah i
snuck in here but you know i just i want
to talk business and it's like what yeah
nah you can't
that's the equivalent of like
you know
when you
crush on a girl way too hard
just like she's like walking into her re
this is something you might
do in like high school or some [ __ ] yeah
so you're seeing your crush walking into
her like pinkberry job and like you're
in the parking lot like wait hey i
didn't see you at six periods she's like
oh [ __ ]
how do you know this is that a different
for perfume than you normally wear is
that a different perfume perfume perfume
i mean you still smell amazing
it's just different from what you
normally smell like
get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah man
poor guy
you dropped some hair
i don't i just can't tell if he's like
like in a manic state
like is he gonna come to and like you
know is he just gonna go off the grid
for a year and then come too and be like
make us all feel bad and be like
hey everyone um i'm the uh logan i can i
have a job guy uh it turns out
undiagnosed uh bipolar maybe and um
taking steps to handle it now more
likely i think it's like a bad
manifestation of like hustler culture
could be that yeah
because i don't know it's just like
that i think i'm like that's like a big
part of his fan base
yeah that's true yeah i think he
attracts that like with oh i don't know
money making stuff and it's like you
know it's just dudes that are like i
want to be like you but like quickly
yeah and so like i think they'd think
that his advice would be like just go
out there and take what you want such a
crazy way to [ __ ] just
make me like you
make me like
come on logan
it's for egg doll yeah
freaky friday freaky friday friday
it does happen logan's in his body
no wait no no no no no no no no no
oh
who gets to be the church now logan
you want a job sorry
now i'm gonna go jack off with your
penis in the mirror
don't touch my dick
that's gay that's weird why is it weird
it's mine now
he's like hitting it on stuff yeah stop
doing it dude i'm ruining my friend stop
look at this
just there in the venue yeah look
everyone's like whoa logan what the [ __ ]
dude it's not me
[Music]
hey everyone look it
[Music]
damn
that would be that's the only way to get
like
the paul brothers
it's the freaky friday their [ __ ] and
just make them wake up to someone else
in their body ruining their brand
uh i'm logan i'm on impulsive the
biggest podcast ever and i'm ending it
[Laughter]
or switching to jake's body and be like
uh what's up it's jake i'm gonna street
fight i'm gonna street fight brock
lesnar right now
what are you doing
no you're gonna get
what's up guys i'm gonna rematch tyron
woodley mma four ounce gloves i'm gonna
do it one-handed i told him i'm gonna
tie one hand in my pants
so pretty easy fight that's happening
tomorrow yeah
live on twitch we're just skipping the
negotiation process so in case i didn't
happen to be jake looks to the tv camera
there's no way of stopping me
uh guys tomorrow i'm going to be live
streaming my head butting competition
with a brick wall
really looking forward to it
or just something like
oh like the the free jumping squirrel
suit [ __ ]
i'm gonna do that out of an airplane
tomorrow
no no i'm not gonna do any training i'm
just gonna go for it yeah [ __ ] it
actually that's too quick dying is too
quick it has to be more uh you know yeah
a lot more gradual yeah
like doing the impulsive podcast and
then getting a brain sponsor be like
guys we want to thank
some brand
these guys [ __ ] suck i'm not reading
that
it just does that for every brand just a
slow whittling away i take blue chew
every single day
every day and it's killed my ability to
get a natural boner
i can't achieve an erection naturally
anymore
unless i watch anime
so
yeah i think logan definitely should
hire